- Bentornato a Capire l'Informazione
e il Calcolo Quantistico.
Mi chiamo John Watrous e sono
il direttore tecnico di IBM Quantum Education.
Questa è la sesta lezione della serie ed è la seconda lezione della
seconda unità della serie, dedicata agli algoritmi quantistici.
Nella lezione precedente abbiamo discusso il modello
di calcolo basato su query, e abbiamo visto che in quel modello, gli algoritmi quantistici possono
offrire un vantaggio sorprendente
rispetto agli algoritmi classici, incluso un vantaggio esponenziale nel caso del problema di Simon.
Purtroppo, il modello
di query non ha davvero alcuna rilevanza
pratica diretta o immediata.
La nozione di scatola nera è un'astrazione
molto utile, come si scopre, ma abbiamo del lavoro da
fare se vogliamo applicare
le intuizioni che abbiamo
ottenuto dal modello di query a un contesto computazionale più standard, dove gli input sono dati come stringhe di bit
piuttosto che come oracoli o scatole nere.
Lo scopo principale di questa lezione è stabilire una base
da cui possiamo farlo.
Ecco una panoramica della lezione. Per gran parte della lezione, ci concentreremo
sul costo computazionale,
ovvero quanto sono difficili diverse
attività computazionali e come possiamo misurare tale difficoltà.
In parole povere, questo si traduce in quanto a lungo dobbiamo aspettare
che i calcoli finiscano e, in ultima analisi, quali
problemi computazionali
possiamo risolvere e quali
sono al di là della nostra portata.
Inizieremo con
un paio di esempi: la fattorizzazione intera e il calcolo del massimo comune
divisore, o MCD in breve.
Sono ottimi esempi per illustrare i
principi sottostanti, ed entrambi capitano
di essere altamente rilevanti per l'algoritmo di Shor, che discuteremo nella prossima lezione,
quindi otterremo effettivamente
il doppio del vantaggio da questi esempi.
Poi discuteremo la nozione di costi computazionali in modo più generale e come possiamo misurarli.
Ci sono molti modi diversi
in cui questo può essere fatto, ma ci concentreremo abbastanza
strettamente su come possiamo farlo con i modelli di circuit del calcolo,
in particolare i circuit booleani
e i quantum circuit.
L'attenzione qui sarà sugli algoritmi piuttosto che sull'hardware del computer,
per esempio, e saremo più preoccupati
di come i costi di
esecuzione di un algoritmo scalino man mano che le specifiche istanze di problema su cui viene eseguito crescono in dimensione, piuttosto
che di quanti secondi,
minuti o ore richieda
un particolare calcolo.
L'idea che motiva questo punto di vista è che gli algoritmi hanno
un'importanza fondamentale.
Ancora oggi stiamo
eseguendo algoritmi che sono stati sviluppati
molto, molto tempo fa e, in modo del tutto naturale, verranno distribuiti
contro istanze di problemi sempre
più grandi usando hardware più veloce e più affidabile man mano che la tecnologia si sviluppa.
E il modo in cui scalano ci dice moltissimo
su quanto siano utili e su quanto continueranno a esserlo.
Nell'ultima sezione della lezione, ci rivolgeremo a un compito di fondamentale importanza, ovvero l'esecuzione di calcoli classici
sui computer quantistici. Il motivo per cui questo è importante non è perché speriamo di sostituire i computer classici
con i computer quantistici,
cosa che sembra estremamente improbabile accada presto, se mai accadrà, ma piuttosto perché apre
molte interessanti possibilità
per gli algoritmi quantistici.
In particolare, una volta che sappiamo come eseguire calcoli classici
sui computer quantistici, questi diventano disponibili agli algoritmi quantistici come subroutine
così possiamo effettivamente
sfruttare tutto ciò che sappiamo sugli algoritmi classici nella ricerca di vantaggi computazionali quantistici.
I computer classici che abbiamo oggi sono davvero meraviglie della tecnologia.
Sono incredibilmente veloci, ma non così veloci che nessun problema computazionale
sia al di là della loro portata.
Alcuni problemi computazionali
sono così intrinsecamente difficili che, sebbene abbiamo
algoritmi per risolverli, nessun computer sul pianeta Terra oggi
è abbastanza veloce da eseguire questi
algoritmi fino al completamento anche su input di dimensioni moderate nell'arco della vita di un essere umano
o anche nell'arco della vita
della Terra stessa.
Per spiegare ulteriormente, diamo un'occhiata al
problema della fattorizzazione intera.
L'enunciato del problema è molto semplice. L'input del problema è un intero N che è almeno due, e l'output è la
fattorizzazione in primi di N,
e ciò significa un elenco dei fattori primi di N insieme alle potenze a cui questi numeri primi devono essere elevati
per ottenere N
moltiplicandoli tutti insieme.
Naturalmente, possiamo sempre moltiplicare i fattori primi insieme in qualsiasi ordine, ma a parte il loro ordinamento,
le fattorizzazioni in primi sono sempre uniche per ogni scelta di N.
Questo fatto si chiama
teorema fondamentale dell'aritmetica, e se sei interessato
ad approfondire, è qualcosa che puoi trovare
all'inizio di
molti libri di teoria dei numeri.
Come esempio molto semplice, ecco la fattorizzazione in primi
del numero 12.
È due alla potenza due
per tre alla potenza uno.
WEBVTT
Non sorprende che un
computer possa dirtelo in un batter d'occhio semplicemente cercando
iterativamente i fattori primi.
Ecco un altro esempio. Non cercherò di leggere questo numero.
È circa 3,4 quattuordecilioni, e devo ammettere che trovo strano che esista persino un nome del genere,
ma comunque, ha 46 cifre decimali e qui puoi vedere
la sua fattorizzazione in primi.
Un computer può dirtelo anche questo. Ho fattorizzato questo numero usando il metodo di fattorizzazione incluso nella libreria di matematica simbolica
per Python,
e ci ha messo qualche secondo, che non è un tempo particolarmente lungo, ma c'è stato un ritardo percettibile.
E certamente il metodo factor N non trova questa fattorizzazione in primi cercando ingenuamente i fattori primi.
In realtà usa un ibrido
di diversi algoritmi, incluso uno chiamato
algoritmo della riga colorata, che è un algoritmo per la fattorizzazione
più sofisticato della ricerca iterativa ingenua
di fattori primi, e sebbene possa sembrare
un numero abbastanza grande,
come input a un problema computazionale, in realtà non è poi così grande.
Sono solo 46 caratteri.
Ecco un altro esempio. È un numero con 309 cifre decimali.
Se lo scriviamo in notazione binaria, ha 1.024 bit ed è per questo
che si chiama RSA1024.
La fattorizzazione in primi di questo numero non è attualmente nota.
Questo numero proviene dalla
sfida di fattorizzazione RSA, gestita da RSA
Laboratories dal 1991 al 2007.
Offrivano premi in denaro
per le fattorizzazioni in primi di vari numeri di dimensioni crescenti,
incluso questo, che valeva 100.000 dollari USA,
ma quel premio non è mai stato riscosso.
La sicurezza del sistema
di crittografia a chiave pubblica RSA si basa sulla difficoltà
della fattorizzazione intera.
Se riesci a fattorizzare, puoi
rompere il sistema, e quindi lo scopo della sfida era fondamentalmente quello di monitorare lo
stato dell'arte nella fattorizzazione.
Il risultato è che
fattorizzare questo numero è al di là delle nostre attuali capacità.
Per quanto ne sappiamo, il
problema stesso è troppo complesso per i computer classici
da risolvere in pratica.
Il numero sfida RSA più grande ad essere stato fattorizzato finora, tra l'altro, ha 250 cifre decimali.
Potrebbe essere un po' difficile
leggerlo sullo schermo, ma ecco la fattorizzazione in primi
di RSA250.
È stata eseguita nel 2020 usando un algoritmo noto come il crivello del campo numerico, ed è stato uno sforzo collettivo che ha coinvolto decine di migliaia
di computer in tutto il mondo.
Ora consideriamo un diverso
problema computazionale, ovvero il problema del calcolo del massimo comune
divisore, o MCD in breve,
di due interi non negativi.
Ecco un enunciato del problema. L'input consiste di due
numeri questa volta, N e M,
e assumeremo che
non siano entrambi uguali a zero.
L'obiettivo è calcolare il
MCD di questi due numeri, che è il più grande intero D che divide esattamente sia N che M,
e se pensi alle
fattorizzazioni in primi di N e M, scoprirai che l'MCD è il prodotto di tutti i numeri primi
che dividono sia N che M elevati al minimo delle potenze che compaiono nelle due
fattorizzazioni in primi.
Quindi è correlato al problema
della fattorizzazione intera, ma risulta essere molto, molto più semplice
da risolvere per i computer. Possiamo calcolare gli MCD per numeri con migliaia di cifre
in un batter d'occhio.
È un po' inutile cercare di mostrarti esempi sullo schermo perché potremmo riempire l'intero schermo con le cifre e staremmo ancora descrivendo
istanze facilmente risolvibili di questo problema.
Ma se sei interessato, segui il link nella descrizione del video alla pagina del libro di testo per questa lezione e troverai le celle di codice
per i tipi di calcoli
di cui sto parlando, inclusi quelli che calcolano
gli MCD di grandi numeri, e puoi provarli tu stesso.
La domanda è: perché è possibile calcolare gli MCD così facilmente?
E la risposta a questa domanda è che abbiamo algoritmi efficienti
per calcolare gli MCD.
Tra questi c'è l'algoritmo di Euclide, scoperto oltre 2.000 anni fa, ma ci sono anche altri
algoritmi MCD efficienti.
E naturalmente stiamo parlando di algoritmi classici qui, quindi questo porta a un'altra domanda.
Potrebbe esistere un efficiente
algoritmo classico per la fattorizzazione intera
che ci permetterebbe di fattorizzare numeri come RSA1024
in un batter d'occhio?
E la risposta è sì. Assolutamente potrebbe esserci un efficiente algoritmo classico
per la fattorizzazione e attualmente non conosciamo alcun modo
di escludere quella possibilità. Tutto ciò che possiamo dire è che
non ne abbiamo ancora trovato uno.
Per tutti gli algoritmi di
fattorizzazione classica che conosciamo, stiamo ancora essenzialmente
cercando i fattori
e questo mette numeri come
RSA1024 fuori dalla nostra portata.
Gli algoritmi MCD efficienti,
d'altra parte, semplicemente non funzionano in quel modo.
Non cercano un
massimo comune divisore. Lo costruiscono effettivamente con una procedura meccanica che è approssimativamente comparabile in costo
alla moltiplicazione degli stessi
due numeri, e dirò qualcosa di più a riguardo più avanti nella lezione.
WEBVTT
Tutto questo sta naturalmente portando
all'algoritmo di Shor, che vedremo nella prossima lezione, ovvero un efficiente algoritmo quantistico
per il calcolo delle fattorizzazioni in primi, ma abbiamo ancora del terreno
da coprire prima di arrivarci.
Parleremo ora
di un framework matematico attraverso il quale possiamo misurare i costi computazionali
di diversi algoritmi,
inclusi quelli di cui abbiamo già parlato.
Per essere chiari, ci concentreremo molto strettamente sui circuit, che sono solo una piccola parte
di un argomento molto più ampio.
Cominciamo con una visione ad altissimo livello di un calcolo ordinario
dalla lezione precedente, il che significa in particolare che non stiamo pensando
ai problemi di query,
ma stiamo pensando a
problemi in cui l'input è dato esplicitamente come una stringa binaria.
Come ho detto nella lezione precedente, potremmo ovviamente consentire
altri simboli se volessimo, ma manteniamo le cose semplici e limitiamoci alle stringhe binarie
sia per l'input che per l'output.
Il calcolo stesso potrebbe essere modellato o descritto in vari modi, come con il modello della macchina
di Turing,
Boolean circuit, quantum circuit, o programmi scritti in
un linguaggio come Python o qualsiasi altro linguaggio a tua scelta.
Come ho detto un momento fa, ci concentreremo sui
circuit, booleani e quantistici.
Innanzitutto, passiamo ancora un po' di tempo a parlare dell'input e dell'output, che assumiamo siano stringhe binarie.
Usando le stringhe binarie, possiamo codificare molti diversi tipi di
oggetti matematici, come numeri, vettori,
matrici, grafi,
descrizioni di molecole, per esempio, nonché elenchi di tutti questi oggetti e di altri ancora.
Come esempio molto semplice, se vogliamo codificare interi non negativi
come stringhe binarie, possiamo usare la notazione binaria.
In questa tabella vedrai i primi 13
interi non negativi insieme alle loro
rappresentazioni o codifiche binarie.
Nella terza colonna puoi vedere la lunghezza di
ciascuna di queste codifiche, che è semplicemente il numero totale di bit necessari per la codifica,
e qui c'è una semplice formula che ti dice esattamente quanti bit
sono necessari in generale per qualsiasi intero non negativo N.
Nota in particolare che
la lunghezza della codifica è generalmente molto più piccola
del numero stesso.
È logaritmica nel numero.
RSA1024, per esempio, ha una codifica di lunghezza 1.024, ma il numero stesso è
ovviamente molto più grande di quello.
Questo schema di codifica funziona
per gli interi non negativi, ma se vogliamo gestire
interi arbitrari, inclusi quelli negativi, possiamo
semplicemente aggiungere un bit di segno.
Possiamo anche consentire un numero qualsiasi di zeri iniziali in queste codifiche se vogliamo che le codifiche
riempiano un blocco di bit o un register di dimensione fissa
purché sia abbastanza grande. A volte è molto conveniente.
Questo non è l'unico modo per codificare gli interi come stringhe di bit.
Ci sono altri modi per farlo, ma questo è un modo abbastanza
standard.
Per altri tipi di oggetti che potrebbero formare gli input o gli output dei
problemi computazionali che ci interessano, possiamo ideare
altri schemi di codifica.
Per esempio, pensa a come
potresti codificare un vettore o un grafo come stringa binaria, oppure pensa a come potresti codificare
due stringhe binarie in
una singola stringa binaria usando solo i simboli zero e uno senza uno spazio o qualsiasi altro simbolo
per separare le due stringhe. Ci sono certamente modi per
farlo, e in effetti abbiamo molta libertà
su come esattamente farlo.
Spesso non ci sarà un modo standard o universalmente concordato per codificare qualunque cosa di cui stiamo parlando
come stringa binaria,
ma va bene, possiamo semplicemente sceglierne uno o inventarne uno nuovo se preferiamo.
Da un punto di vista puramente formale, pensiamo ai calcoli come trasformazioni essenzialmente meccaniche su stringhe di bit
e le specifiche degli
schemi di codifica che usiamo sono certamente importanti a qualche livello.
Ma tuttavia, quando progettiamo e
analizziamo gli algoritmi, di solito non ci preoccupiamo molto delle specifiche degli
schemi di codifica.
Se chiedi a due persone diverse di trovare un modo per codificare, diciamo, molecole di un certo
tipo come stringhe binarie,
potresti aspettarti che trovino modi diversi per farlo, ma se fossero persone ragionevoli che sapessero cosa stanno facendo,
potresti anche ragionevolmente aspettarti che sarebbe un processo computazionale abbastanza
semplice tradurre avanti e indietro tra i due schemi di codifica,
richiedendo molto probabilmente un calcolo molto
diretto che sarebbe piuttosto semplice rispetto al calcolo effettivo
a cui siamo interessati.
Il risultato è che i dettagli relativi agli schemi di codifica che usiamo sono spesso abbastanza secondari e la nostra attenzione è sugli
algoritmi stessi.
Nulla di tutto questo sarà un problema per questa lezione, tra l'altro. Ci concentreremo principalmente su problemi che riguardano gli interi, che assumeremo siano codificati in binario,
ma è qualcosa di cui essere consapevoli.
In generale, per qualunque tipo di problema di cui stiamo parlando, la lunghezza dell'input si riferisce
al numero di bit necessari per codificare l'input,
e consideriamo la lunghezza dell'input come la dimensione dell'istanza del problema di cui stiamo pensando.
Ora consideriamo
il calcolo stesso, che è rappresentato dal
rettangolo blu in questa figura.
Il modo in cui misureremo
il costo di questo calcolo è contare il numero di operazioni elementari che richiede.
Intuitivamente, un'operazione elementare è una che coinvolge un piccolo numero fisso
di bit o qubit
che può essere eseguita rapidamente e facilmente, come calcolare l'AND di
due bit, per esempio.
WEBVTT
A un livello formale,
ci sono diversi modi per definire cos'è un'operazione elementare, a seconda di quale
modello computazionale stiamo usando.
Per esempio, un'operazione elementare potrebbe essere un passo di una macchina di Turing se stessimo usando quel modello.
Ai fini di questa lezione, ci concentreremo sui modelli di circuit, come ho già detto, e in particolare sui quantum
e Boolean circuit.
Quando lavoriamo con i circuit, è tipico che pensiamo a ogni gate come a un'operazione elementare.
Abbiamo visto diversi quantum gate finora nella serie,
tra cui gate X, Y e Z, gate Hadamard, gate S e T,
gate controlled NOT, gate swap, gate Toffoli e gate Fredkin.
Abbiamo anche parlato dei query gate nel contesto del modello di query, ma non lavoreremo nel modello di query in questa lezione, quindi non ci preoccuperemo dei
query gate per ora.
Abbiamo anche visto che qualsiasi operazione unitaria su qualsiasi numero di qubit
può essere vista come un gate se vogliamo farlo.
Ai fini della misurazione del costo però, questo non sarà molto utile, quindi quello che faremo è semplicemente scegliere un insieme di gate
e considereremo quell'insieme come il nostro insieme di operazioni elementari.
Innanzitutto, includeremo i
single qubit unitary gate che vedi qui,
ovvero gate X, Y e Z,
gate Hadamard e gate S e T, nonché i loro inversi
o trasposti coniugati.
Non abbiamo effettivamente bisogno di tutti questi gate. Non appena abbiamo i gate Hadamard e T, possiamo implementare il resto di essi,
ma solo per comodità, li includeremo tutti.
Includeremo anche i gate controlled NOT, e questi saranno gli unici
gate multi-qubit nel nostro insieme.
E infine includeremo le misurazioni in base standard a single qubit, in modo da poter effettivamente ottenere alcune informazioni classiche
in uscita dai nostri circuit.
Se ci concentriamo solo sui gate unitari e dimentichiamo per un momento le
misurazioni, otteniamo quello che si chiama
un insieme di gate universale.
Ciò significa che
qualsiasi operazione unitaria su qualsiasi numero di qubit può
essere implementata esattamente
o con una precisione arbitrariamente elevata
con un quantum circuit costruito solo con questi gate.
In altre parole, questo è un
insieme di gate sufficientemente buono da permetterci di costruire qualsiasi operazione unitaria
a partire da essi.
Non necessariamente in modo esatto, ma possiamo ottenere un'approssimazione
buona quanto vogliamo.
Ciò potrebbe richiedere molti gate, e in realtà non è troppo difficile ragionare sul fatto che a volte deve richiederne molti,
ma tuttavia, è sempre possibile.
Non è semplice dimostrare che questo è un insieme di gate universale, e non discuteremo come
viene fatto nella serie,
ma è un fatto abbastanza noto e ci sono in effetti diversi
modi in cui può essere dimostrato.
Ci sono anche altri insiemi di gate che a volte vengono usati
al posto di questo, come i gate Toffoli, i gate Hadamard e i gate S oltre alle misurazioni,
ma questa è una scelta abbastanza standard.
Quindi, in sintesi, queste sono
le operazioni quantistiche che considereremo elementari.
Per i Boolean circuit,
considereremo questi quattro gate come
operazioni elementari: gate AND, gate OR, gate NOT e FANOUT.
Il FANOUT, tra l'altro, non è
sempre contato come un gate, ma sarà
importante farlo come vedremo più avanti nella lezione.
Analogamente a quanto avevamo per
il nostro insieme di gate quantistici standard, questo insieme è un po' ridondante.
Non hai bisogno di entrambi AND e OR. Puoi creare uno dei due usando l'altro con tre gate NOT,
ma non fa male includerli entrambi ed è solo comodo.
Come potresti già sapere, questo è un insieme di gate universale
per i calcoli deterministici, il che significa che qualsiasi funzione
da bit a bit
può essere implementata con un Boolean circuit composto da gate di questa collezione.
Ancora una volta, proprio come avevamo
per i quantum circuit, questo non significa che ogni funzione possa essere implementata efficientemente
da un Boolean circuit,
e in effetti la maggior parte delle funzioni
può essere implementata solo con circuit molto grandi
per il semplice motivo che ci sono moltissime funzioni
e non tutte possono avere circuit piccoli. Non ci sono abbastanza
circuit piccoli in circolazione.
L'universalità è più facile
da dimostrare in questo caso che nel caso quantistico, a quanto pare.
Quindi se non sai già
come dimostrarla, riflettici
e vedi se riesci a capirlo, se ne hai voglia.
Ora che abbiamo deciso i
gate che permetteremo e che considereremo
operazioni elementari, possiamo pensare a quanti di essi
sono necessari per eseguire
vari calcoli.
Per farlo, useremo
questa definizione per la dimensione di un circuit.
Questa definizione funziona sia per
i Boolean che per i quantum circuit ed è molto semplice.
La dimensione di un circuit è il
numero totale di gate che ha.
Per esempio, se torniamo
allo stesso esempio che abbiamo visto più volte, ovvero il nostro Boolean circuit per calcolare lo XOR esclusivo di due bit,
vediamo che ha dimensione sette
perché ci sono sette gate: due gate FANOUT, due gate NOT,
due gate AND e un gate OR. Se decidessimo di non contare
i gate FANOUT, il che è comune, avrebbe dimensione cinque,
ma contiamo i gate FANOUT, quindi la sua dimensione è sette.
WEBVTT
La dimensione di un circuit
corrisponde al numero di operazioni elementari
che dobbiamo eseguire.
Quindi, se dovessimo eseguire
quelle operazioni sequenzialmente, la dimensione ci direbbe
quanto tempo ci vorrebbe,
quindi puoi pensare alla dimensione del circuit come alla rappresentazione del tempo di esecuzione sequenziale.
Questo è il modo in cui
misureremo il costo computazionale ai fini di questa lezione.
C'è un'altra proprietà
dei circuit però che può anche essere vista come la quantità di tempo
necessaria per eseguire un circuit, ed è la profondità del circuit.
Per essere precisi, la profondità
è il numero massimo di gate incontrati su qualsiasi percorso da un filo di input a un filo di output,
che equivale al numero di strati di gate necessari
per creare il circuit, dove uno strato si riferisce a un gruppo di gate
che potrebbero essere eseguiti simultaneamente perché non hanno
fili in comune.
Per esempio, il nostro circuit
di prima ha profondità quattro, e possiamo vedere direttamente dal diagramma che ci sono quattro strati.
I gate FANOUT possono essere
eseguiti simultaneamente, i gate NOT possono essere
eseguiti simultaneamente e i gate AND possono essere
eseguiti simultaneamente.
Possiamo quindi pensare alla profondità del circuit come alla rappresentazione del tempo di esecuzione parallela.
La profondità del circuit è certamente una nozione interessante e importante e ci sono alcune tecniche molto
sofisticate che possono essere usate per ridurre
la profondità richiesta per alcuni calcoli, a volte in modo abbastanza drammatico, ma è un argomento avanzato
e non avremo molto altro da dire a riguardo in questa serie.
Quindi, ancora una volta, misureremo
il costo computazionale in termini di dimensione del circuit
o, in altre parole,
il numero di operazioni elementari necessarie per eseguire un calcolo.
All'inizio della lezione, abbiamo parlato del problema della
fattorizzazione intera e abbiamo visto che il tempo richiesto da un algoritmo per risolvere questo problema
può aumentare man mano che gli input crescono in lunghezza, e questo è tipicamente
il problema su cui ci concentriamo
quando analizziamo gli algoritmi.
Ovvero, siamo interessati a come i costi di esecuzione degli algoritmi scalino man mano che gli input diventano sempre più grandi.
Naturalmente, questo tipo di scaling non è l'unica cosa che conta.
Per esempio, potremmo semplicemente essere interessati a trovare i fattori
di RSA1024 e basta.
Quindi in un caso del genere, parleremmo di una
singola istanza di problema in cui nulla cresce.
Ma quando pensiamo agli algoritmi, il modo in cui i loro costi
scalano è molto importante e ci dice molto
sugli algoritmi.
Questo punto di vista è
coerente con l'idea che gli algoritmi siano fondamentali, e come ho detto prima,
con il passare del tempo e il progredire della tecnologia, verranno distribuiti contro
input sempre più grandi.
Ma nota che mentre gli input ai problemi computazionali
possono crescere in dimensione, i circuit non crescono.
Ogni circuit ha una dimensione fissa.
E per questo motivo, se vogliamo descrivere un
algoritmo usando i circuit, avremo effettivamente bisogno di una famiglia di circuit per farlo,
e per famiglia di circuit intendiamo una collezione di circuit che diventa sempre più grande in modo da poter accogliere gli input
man mano che diventano sempre più grandi. Per esempio, consideriamo un algoritmo deterministico classico
per il problema della fattorizzazione intera, forse uno basato sulla divisione di prova, ma i dettagli non contano davvero
ai fini di questo esempio.
Potremmo in linea di principio
descrivere tale algoritmo usando una famiglia di Boolean circuit, dove se vogliamo fattorizzare un numero
la cui rappresentazione binaria ha N bit, prendiamo il circuit CN dalla nostra famiglia e inseriamo il numero
che vogliamo fattorizzare
nei bit di input di quel circuit.
A volte potremmo scegliere di parametrizzare questi
circuit in modi diversi, quindi potrebbe non essere sempre il caso che l'N-esimo circuit abbia N bit di input,
ma è un modo abbastanza tipico di farlo. Naturalmente, man mano che le lunghezze degli input aumentano, ci aspetteremmo che i circuit
in questa famiglia diventino più grandi
a riflettere il fatto che
fattorizzare numeri a quattro bit è molto più semplice che fattorizzare numeri a 1.024 bit, per esempio.
E quindi, con questo in mente, misuriamo il costo di tale
algoritmo con una funzione, che ci dice quante
operazioni elementari
servono per ogni possibile lunghezza di input, e possiamo farlo sia per gli algoritmi classici che quantistici.
Come esempio, consideriamo il problema dell'addizione intera, che è certamente molto
più semplice della fattorizzazione
o anche del calcolo degli MCD.
Solo per semplicità, supponiamo che sia N che
M siano interi non negativi e che siano rappresentati
da stringhe binarie della stessa lunghezza.
Come potremmo costruire Boolean circuit che sommano questi due numeri?
Beh, cominciamo con un algoritmo, l'algoritmo standard per l'addizione, che è l'analogo in base due del metodo
che presumo abbiamo tutti imparato per sommare numeri insieme con
una matita e un pezzo di carta, quindi iniziamo con i
bit meno significativi,
li sommiamo, e ciò ci dà il bit meno
significativo del risultato insieme a un bit di riporto
che dobbiamo considerare
quando passiamo alla posizione successiva. E continuiamo a scorrere i bit, generando bit di output
insieme ai bit di riporto
finché non arriviamo alla fine.
WEBVTT
Questo metodo può essere
espresso abbastanza direttamente in termini di Boolean circuit.
Un modo di pensarci è iniziare con un piccolo circuit per sommare due interi a singolo bit insieme.
Questo ci darà un numero
tra zero e due, dove il bit meno significativo è lo XOR dei bit di input
e il bit più significativo, o bit di riporto se preferisci, è l'AND dei due bit di input.
A volte ci riferiamo a un circuit che esegue queste
due operazioni insieme come semi-sommatore.
Questo va bene quando ci sono
solo due bit di input, ma se vogliamo sommare interi con più di un bit ciascuno,
dovremo gestire
i bit di riporto in qualche modo.
Quindi quello che possiamo fare è collegare in cascata
due semi-sommatori e prendere l'OR dei
bit di riporto che producono per creare quello che si chiama un sommatore completo,
che è fondamentalmente un Boolean circuit per sommare tre numeri a
singolo bit insieme.
E una volta che abbiamo un sommatore completo, possiamo sommare numeri insieme
semplicemente a cascata, procedendo dal bit meno significativo
a quello più significativo. Stiamo sostanzialmente implementando l'algoritmo di addizione standard usando i sommatori completi per
gestire i bit di riporto.
Quindi qual è il costo di questo calcolo?
Beh, abbiamo bisogno di sette gate elementari
per ogni gate XOR, il che significa 10 gate per un semi-sommatore
e quindi 21 gate per un sommatore completo, che è due semi-sommatori più un gate OR.
Quindi alla fine, se i nostri numeri di input hanno entrambi AND bit, abbiamo bisogno di un semi-sommatore per
il bit meno significativo
e di un sommatore completo per ogni altro bit, e il risultato finale è 21 per N meno uno più 10, ovvero 21N meno 11 gate in totale.
Se per qualche motivo decidessimo che non vogliamo
contare i gate FANOUT e includessimo i gate XOR
nel nostro insieme di gate, avremmo bisogno di cinque N meno
tre gate in totale.
È bello sapere esattamente quanti gate o operazioni elementari sono necessari per eseguire diversi calcoli,
come abbiamo appena visto con l'addizione intera.
E naturalmente, se vogliamo effettivamente implementare questi calcoli, dobbiamo conoscere questi dettagli.
Ma se entriamo sempre in questo livello di dettaglio, soprattutto per
algoritmi più complicati, saremo molto rapidamente sepolti in dettagli
che in molti casi hanno
importanza secondaria.
Un modo per semplificare le cose che è molto comune nell'
analisi degli algoritmi è utilizzare la notazione O-grande,
che ci permette di esprimere
e confrontare i tassi di crescita in un modo abbastanza semplice
che è molto conveniente.
E qui puoi vedere la definizione che sottende questa notazione.
Supponiamo di avere
due funzioni G e H, che possiamo pensare come prendenti valori interi non negativi per semplicità,
sebbene ciò non sia effettivamente richiesto. Forse G e H rappresentano i costi di diversi calcoli, per esempio.
Diciamo quindi che G è O-grande di H, che è tradizionalmente scritto
con un segno uguale come questo.
Se G di N è al più una
costante positiva C per H di N, purché N sia abbastanza grande.
Quindi si tratta di cosa
succede quando N diventa grande.
Formalmente, ciò che significa abbastanza grande è che esiste una scelta di N zero tale che la disuguaglianza sia vera
ogni volta che N è almeno N zero.
La chiave qui è che questi
numeri C e N zero sono fissi.
Possono essere qualsiasi numero,
ma qualunque cosa siano, non possono cambiare al crescere di N.
Se non hai mai visto
questo tipo di definizione prima, potrebbe volerci un po' per abituarsi e puoi trovare risorse
che spiegheranno questo concetto
con molto più dettaglio
di quanto io possa fare in questa lezione.
Di solito quello che facciamo è scegliere
la funzione H in modo che sia semplice per esprimere qualcosa su quanto rapidamente cresce la funzione G.
Per esempio, la funzione il cui valore è 17 per N cubo meno 257
per N quadrato più
65.537 è O-grande di N cubo, e puoi adattare questo
esempio alla definizione
scegliendo C e N zero appropriatamente.
Per esempio, se prendiamo C uguale a 18, avremo che
l'espressione è effettivamente al più 18 per N cubo
purché N sia abbastanza grande.
Collegando questa notazione all'
esempio dell'addizione intera, quello che possiamo ora dire è che esiste una famiglia di Boolean circuit
per sommare interi non negativi tali che la dimensione dell'N-esimo circuit, ovvero quello che funziona
per input di lunghezza N
è O-grande di N. La dimensione effettiva di CN
secondo la nostra analisi era 21 per N meno 11,
ma è O-grande di N.
Non è sempre conveniente scartare dettagli come questo, ma qui ha senso
perché rivela la natura essenziale dell'algoritmo di addizione standard, ovvero che il suo costo scala linearmente
nella dimensione dei numeri
che stiamo sommando, e questa espressione non è sensibile ad alcuni dei dettagli di basso livello del nostro modello,
come precisamente quali gate consideriamo operazioni elementari.
Per esempio, se decidessimo che i gate XOR dovrebbero essere considerati come
operazioni elementari o che i gate FANOUT non dovrebbero
contare come gate o entrambi,
avremmo ancora che l'addizione intera può essere calcolata al costo O-grande di N.
WEBVTT
Ecco un altro esempio di
un problema computazionale: la moltiplicazione di interi.
Analogamente all'addizione, possiamo chiederci qual è il costo
di questo calcolo.
Se consideriamo il l'algoritmo standard
di moltiplicazione, ovvero l'analogo in base due del metodo per moltiplicare numeri
insegnato nelle scuole elementari,
che è fondamentalmente solo
traslare e sommare quando lavoriamo con numeri in binario, troviamo che ci sono Boolean circuit di dimensione O-grande di N al quadrato
per moltiplicare interi a N bit.
Non entrerò nei dettagli di questo. Naturalmente i circuit sono un
po' più complicati di quelli per l'addizione, ma se pensi al modo
in cui funziona l'algoritmo standard
di moltiplicazione, non dovrebbe sorprendere.
In sostanza, dobbiamo fare
circa N addizioni, ciascuna con costo lineare, e quindi otteniamo un
costo quadratico complessivo.
Questo può essere generalizzato. Se uno dei numeri ha N bit e l'altro ne ha M bit, allora abbiamo bisogno di circuit di
dimensione O-grande di N per M.
Qui, tra l'altro, stiamo usando un'estensione della notazione O-grande dove abbiamo più variabili, ma può essere estesa così,
e se sei interessato
ai dettagli specifici, ti rimando al
contenuto del libro di testo per la lezione, che è di nuovo linkato nella
descrizione del video.
È in realtà possibile
moltiplicare due interi a N bit in un modo
asintoticamente superiore all'algoritmo standard di moltiplicazione.
In particolare, l'algoritmo di moltiplicazione di Schonhage-Strassen
moltiplica due interi a N bit con un costo di O-grande di
N per il logaritmo di N
per il logaritmo del logaritmo di N. Quindi, man mano che N diventa grande, come
decine di migliaia di bit,
questo è effettivamente un modo più
efficiente di moltiplicare, ma è complicato e l'overhead lo rende impraticabile
per numeri più piccoli.
Quindi aggiungiamo la moltiplicazione
al nostro elenco di esempi.
E solo per semplicità, elenchiamo il costo dato dall'algoritmo standard di moltiplicazione, che è O-grande di N al quadrato.
Quindi, ancora una volta, ci stiamo concentrando sulla natura essenziale di questo costo, ovvero che scala quadraticamente
o in modo subquadratico se usiamo metodi asintoticamente superiori.
Possiamo anche considerare il
problema della divisione intera, che è enunciato precisamente sullo schermo.
Qui stiamo parlando di calcolare un quoziente e un resto, quindi la risposta consiste
di due interi, Q e R.
Ancora una volta, c'è un algoritmo standard
per la divisione e ha anche costo quadratico
e, come la moltiplicazione,
ci sono in effetti algoritmi
asintoticamente superiori.
Quindi come si confrontano gli algoritmi MCD?
Beh, l'algoritmo di Euclide risulta
avere costo quadratico, ed è quello che intendevo
prima nella lezione quando dicevo che possiamo calcolare gli MCD
approssimativamente allo stesso costo della moltiplicazione di due numeri.
Ancora una volta, ci sono
algoritmi asintoticamente superiori lungo linee simili a quelle
dell'addizione e della moltiplicazione,
sebbene il costo sia un po'
più alto in questo caso, almeno per quanto ne sappiamo.
Menzionerò solo un altro esempio di problema da aggiungere a questo elenco, ed è l'esponenziazione modulare.
Qui ci sono tre numeri
di input, K, M e N, e l'obiettivo è calcolare
N alla potenza K modulo M,
che significa il resto
dopo aver diviso per M.
Non è affatto ovvio, ma possiamo calcolare l'esponenziazione modulare al costo di qubit, ovvero O-grande di N cubo
per interi a N bit.
Il modo per farlo non è prima calcolare N alla potenza K e poi calcolare il resto.
Anche solo scrivere N alla potenza K potrebbe richiedere esponenzialmente molti bit, quindi quell'approccio non funzionerà.
Invece, possiamo usare un algoritmo
chiamato algoritmo di potenza, detto anche quadratura ripetuta, dove tutto è fatto modulo M
e usiamo i bit di
K per elevare iterativamente al quadrato e moltiplicare in un modo
che fa funzionare tutto.
Quindi questo è più
costoso degli altri, ma possiamo comunque eseguire
l'esponenziazione modulare abbastanza rapidamente su numeri
con molte migliaia di bit.
Quindi come si confrontano i costi di questi compiti con la fattorizzazione intera?
Se cominciamo in modo semplice e
pensiamo alla divisione di prova, dove prima controlliamo se due è un fattore del numero di input
e poi controlliamo tre e così via, otterremo un algoritmo abbastanza
costoso: O-grande di N al quadrato per due
alla potenza N diviso due.
Ogni divisione richiede tempo quadratico e nel caso peggiore dovremo cercare i fattori primi fino alla radice quadrata del numero di input,
e da lì viene
N diviso due. Se non abbiamo trovato un
fattore primo a quel punto, possiamo fermarci perché allora
il numero di input stesso deve essere primo.
Questo è estremamente costoso perché N compare come esponente in questa espressione, il che significa che questo
algoritmo ha costo esponenziale.
Al contrario, tutti gli esempi che abbiamo in questo riquadro qui hanno quello che chiamiamo costo polinomiale, dove N viene elevato a una potenza,
ma quella potenza è sempre un numero fisso che non cresce al crescere
della lunghezza dell'input.
In questi casi, le potenze
sono uno, due e tre.
Tornerò sul costo polinomiale rispetto a quello esponenziale tra un momento, ma prima finiamo
con quello che sappiamo sulla fattorizzazione.
WEBVTT
Prima ho menzionato
il crivello del campo numerico, che è il miglior
algoritmo di fattorizzazione che abbiamo in termini del modo in cui il suo costo scala.
In realtà, il costo di questo algoritmo non è rigorosamente dimostrato perché è connesso ad alcune domande aperte sulla teoria dei numeri,
ma si congettura che abbia
un costo simile a questo.
Questa volta l'O-grande è nell'esponente, ma sorvolo su questo
dettaglio.
Il punto chiave è che è significativamente migliore
della divisione di prova perché, sebbene N compaia nell'esponente,
viene elevato alla potenza 1/3 e ciò si traduce in un costo molto più basso, ecco perché questo algoritmo
riesce a gestire numeri come RSA250, mentre la divisione di prova
certamente non può.
È comunque esponenziale nel senso che una potenza di N compare in un esponente, e quindi, di conseguenza,
non riesce comunque a gestire
numeri come RSA1024.
Ora permettimi di dire qualcosa di più sul costo polinomiale
rispetto al costo esponenziale.
Diciamo che un algoritmo
ha costo polinomiale se il suo costo è O-grande di N alla potenza B,
dove B può essere qualsiasi numero positivo, ma la chiave è che B deve essere fisso, ovvero che non cambia
al crescere della lunghezza dell'input N.
Per gli esempi che abbiamo visto un momento fa, ovvero addizione intera, moltiplicazione, divisione, calcolo degli MCD
e esponenziazione modulare,
avevamo che B era
uno, due o tre.
Questi sono quindi tutti
algoritmi a costo polinomiale.
Ma quando diciamo costo polinomiale
più in generale, B potrebbe essere qualsiasi numero positivo.
Potrebbe anche essere un milione,
ma deve essere fisso.
Come astrazione molto approssimativa, gli algoritmi a costo polinomiale
sono tipicamente considerati come algoritmi efficienti.
È sicuramente una semplificazione eccessiva, ma come linea guida approssimativa, puoi pensare a un algoritmo a costo polinomiale
come a qualcosa che in qualche modo
sfrutta la struttura di un problema per costruire una soluzione, al contrario di un approccio di forza bruta
o di una ricerca esaustiva
su uno spazio molto grande.
Naturalmente, un algoritmo il cui costo scala come N alla potenza un milione
su input di lunghezza N
non sarebbe ragionevolmente
considerato efficiente, e non ci aspetteremmo di poterlo
eseguire su input grandi.
Ma comunque anche un algoritmo di N alla potenza un milione deve fare qualcosa di intelligente che in qualche modo riflette la struttura
di qualsiasi problema che risolve, per evitare lo scaling esponenziale in costo che sarebbe associato a
una ricerca esaustiva su un dominio grande.
E in pratica, l'identificazione di un algoritmo a costo polinomiale è davvero solo un primo
passo verso l'efficienza.
Se un problema è importante
e qualcuno scopre il primo in assoluto algoritmo a costo
polinomiale per esso, magari con un esponente molto grande,
puoi essere ragionevolmente sicuro che i progettisti di algoritmi
troveranno miglioramenti che faranno scendere quell'esponente.
In sostanza, puoi
pensare all'esistenza di un algoritmo a costo
polinomiale per un problema come a una dimostrazione della fattibilità
di risolvere quel problema
su input ragionevolmente grandi, ma ci potrebbe essere ancora molto lavoro necessario per raggiungere la vera efficienza.
Nella teoria della complessità, è tipico dire che il costo di un algoritmo
scala sub-esponenzialmente se il costo è O-grande di due alla potenza N
alla potenza epsilon per ogni numero reale positivo epsilon, e se non è sub-esponenziale,
allora è esponenziale, o potrebbe persino essere super-esponenziale come due alla due alla N,
che è doppialmente esponenziale,
ma finché l'output
non è super-esponenzialmente lungo, ogni problema può effettivamente essere
calcolato da un Boolean circuit
con costo esponenziale, a quanto pare. Quindi la distinzione importante qui è tra costo polinomiale
e costo esponenziale.
Non conosciamo algoritmi classici a costo sub-esponenziale per
la fattorizzazione intera.
Per esempio, il costo del crivello del campo numerico non è O-grande di due
a N alla epsilon quando epsilon è 1/3 o meno,
quindi non soddisfa questa definizione.
È indubbiamente un algoritmo molto intelligente, ma è ancora un crivello e stiamo ancora effettivamente cercando
su uno spazio molto grande per identificare i fattori di un dato numero.
Come vedremo nella prossima lezione, esiste in effetti un algoritmo quantistico a costo polinomiale
per la fattorizzazione intera.
L'algoritmo di Shor ha costo polinomiale e specificamente ha costo di qubit, simile all'esponenziazione modulare.
Un'altra classe di problemi di cui
potresti essere a conoscenza è la classe dei problemi NP-completi.
Non entrerò in cosa sono i problemi NP-completi in questa lezione, ma puoi cercarli
se sei interessato.
Si congettura che
nessuno di questi problemi abbia costo sub-esponenziale.
Questa è essenzialmente una versione basata su circuit di ciò che a volte è chiamata
l'ipotesi del tempo esponenziale, ma finora nessuno è riuscito
a capire come dimostrarla.
In realtà, non possiamo nemmeno dimostrare che non esistano algoritmi a costo lineare per i problemi NP-completi.
È davvero molto difficile, almeno
per quanto ne sappiamo, escludere la possibilità
di una futura scoperta di un algoritmo incredibilmente creativo
per questi problemi.
WEBVTT
Ecco una figura che
illustra la relazione tra costo polinomiale e costo esponenziale.
Sull'asse X abbiamo la lunghezza dell'input per qualunque problema stiamo considerando, e l'asse Y rappresenta il
costo della risoluzione di quel problema
o puoi pensarci
come il tempo necessario per risolvere il problema se preferisci.
Un algoritmo a costo esponenziale
potrebbe scalare così.
Per input brevi, il costo potrebbe non essere particolarmente alto, come la fattorizzazione del
numero 12, per esempio,
ma man mano che la lunghezza dell'input aumenta, il costo alla fine esploderà.
Un algoritmo a costo polinomiale,
d'altra parte, potrebbe avere uno scaling simile a questo.
Il costo aumenterà comunque in generale man mano che gli input diventano più lunghi, e potrebbe persino costare di più dell'algoritmo a costo esponenziale
per alcuni input,
ma alla fine sarà
molto meno costoso dell'algoritmo a costo esponenziale e non esplode nello stesso modo estremo
degli algoritmi a costo esponenziale.
Quindi, se immaginiamo di avere
un costo massimo che siamo disposti a sostenere, o un tempo massimo che siamo disposti ad aspettare per una risposta,
se preferisci pensare al tempo, allora l'algoritmo a costo esponenziale funzionerà solo per input
fino a una determinata lunghezza,
mentre, in generale, l'algoritmo a costo polinomiale ci permetterà di risolvere il
problema per input più grandi.
Ed è per questo che, per esempio, possiamo calcolare facilmente gli MCD per numeri con molte migliaia di
bit, ma nel caso peggiore,
non riusciamo a fattorizzare numeri di questa dimensione.
Nell'ultima parte della lezione, rivolgeremo la nostra attenzione all'implementazione di calcoli classici
sui computer quantistici.
Più specificamente, vedremo
che qualsiasi calcolo che può essere eseguito da un Boolean circuit può anche essere eseguito da un quantum circuit
approssimativamente allo stesso costo. Inoltre, questo può essere
fatto in modo pulito, il che è importante se vogliamo eseguire questi calcoli
come subroutine all'interno di
calcoli quantistici più grandi, e spiegherò cosa intendo per pulito quando entreremo più nel vivo della discussione.
Utilizzeremo i
gate Toffoli in questo processo.
Ricorda che i gate Toffoli sono gate controlled-controlled-NOT, quindi la loro azione sugli stati di base standard
è quella che vedi qui sullo schermo.
Nota che possiamo anche
pensare ai gate Toffoli come query gate
per la funzione AND.
Non si tratta di dire che sono query gate in senso letterale. Come ho menzionato all'inizio della lezione, non stiamo lavorando nel modello di query a questo punto,
ma piuttosto, la loro azione segue lo stesso schema di un query gate.
Possiamo pensare ai valori binari A e B come input alla funzione AND e, come un query gate,
questi valori vengono restituiti in eco
come parte dell'output e il valore della funzione, ovvero l'AND logico di A e B
viene XORato sul qubit inferiore. Ora, non abbiamo incluso i gate Toffoli nel nostro insieme di gate standard.
Potremmo cambiare idea se volessimo, ma non ne abbiamo davvero bisogno
perché in alternativa possiamo implementare i gate Toffoli usando i gate Hadamard,
i gate T e T-dagger
e i gate controlled NOT come vedi qui.
Non è affatto ovvio
che questo particolare circuit implementi un gate Toffoli, ma è così, e puoi o credermi sulla parola
o moltiplicare tutto tu stesso per fare un po' di pratica in più, oppure puoi semplicemente chiedere a Qiskit o Python
o qualsiasi software che moltiplica matrici di fare la moltiplicazione per te.
Puoi anche consultare il
contenuto del libro di testo per la lezione per vedere questo fatto usando Qiskit.
Ora possiamo passare alla simulazione dei gate booleani con i quantum circuit e tutto ciò di cui avremo bisogno per farlo sono i gate NOT,
i gate controlled NOT e i gate Toffoli.
Queste operazioni sono tutte deterministiche oltre a essere unitarie e a volte descriviamo
operazioni come queste come reversibili, e in effetti,
lo studio del calcolo reversibile precede il calcolo quantistico ed è da lì che proviene l'intera
procedura.
I gate booleani di cui dobbiamo preoccuparci sono i gate NOT, i gate Hadamard e i gate FANOUT,
e quello che mostreremo è che possiamo implementare questi gate, o simularli se preferisci, usando i gate NOT,
i gate controlled NOT e i gate Toffoli.
Per essere chiari, ciò che
vogliamo sono quantum circuit che ci permettano di calcolare i valori dei gate booleani che ho appena menzionato
quando gli forniamo qubit in
stati di base standard come input.
Per input di stati quantistici arbitrari, l'azione sarà determinata
dalla linearità come al solito.
Non abbiamo bisogno di fare nulla
di speciale con i gate NOT. I gate NOT sono gate NOT e possono essere implementati direttamente.
E i gate OR possono essere simulati
usando i gate Toffoli e NOT.
I gate AND sono facili, in particolare alla luce di quello che ho appena detto un momento fa sui gate Toffoli che sono essenzialmente
implementazioni di query gate
della funzione AND.
Per essere precisi, quello che possiamo fare è introdurre un nuovo qubit inizializzato allo stato zero
e fare in modo che quel qubit sia il
target del nostro gate Toffoli e che i due qubit di input siano i controlli.
Nomi diversi vengono dati
a questi qubit extra, che vengono spesso introdotti
nei calcoli quantistici, e li chiamerò qubit di workspace solo per scegliere un nome.
WEBVTT
La nostra tipica assunzione sui qubit di workspace è che iniziano nello stato zero e spesso possiamo riportarli
allo stato zero
quando abbiamo finito, ma non sempre.
Nel diagramma abbiamo un ket zero all'interno del rettangolo tratteggiato per indicare che l'inizializzazione di questo qubit
è parte del processo, e se non hai
un qubit fresco come questo, non sarai in grado
di eseguire questa simulazione.
Il qubit di output inferiore
è quello che ci interessa perché è il risultato
dell'operazione AND e abbiamo sostanzialmente
finito con gli altri due
quindi possono restare all'interno della scatola.
In effetti, potresti anche immaginare che sbarazzarsi di questi due qubit faccia parte del lavoro di
simulare questo gate AND,
un po' come spazzatura
che deve essere pulita.
Ma comunque, è così che possiamo
simulare un gate AND.
Ora che sappiamo come fare i gate AND, possiamo fare i gate OR usando
una delle leggi di De Morgan.
Se metti i gate NOT sui due input e sull'output di un gate AND
gate, ottieni un gate OR, quindi è semplice come quello.
E l'ultimo è FANOUT, e per questo uno, tutto ciò di cui
abbiamo bisogno è un gate controlled NOT insieme a un qubit di workspace.
Nello specifico, se impostiamo il qubit di workspace come target, copiamo effettivamente qualsiasi stato di base standard che arriva,
così si comporta come un gate FANOUT.
Abbiamo quindi tutti i nostri gate.
E ora che abbiamo tutti i nostri gate, possiamo passare ai circuit.
Supponiamo di avere
un Boolean circuit di nome C, e questo può essere qualsiasi
Boolean circuit tu scelga
purché sia composto da
gate AND, NOT e FANOUT.
Chiameremo T il numero di gate in C e daremo il nome F alla funzione che C calcola.
Possiamo quindi pensare a F come avente la forma che vedi qui, dove N è il numero di bit di input di C,
M è il numero di bit di output e sigma è l'alfabeto binario.
E quello che facciamo è semplicemente scorrere uno per uno i gate di C.
Lasciamo i gate NOT così come sono e sostituiamo gli altri con le simulazioni
che ho appena descritto.
Quindi se C assomiglia a questo, quello che otteniamo è un circuit
R che assomiglia a questo.
In questo diagramma, tutti
i qubit di workspace che ci servono per le simulazioni sono stati estratti dalle loro scatole e raccolti in basso.
Quindi K è il numero totale di
qubit di workspace di cui abbiamo bisogno, che è uno per ciascuno dei gate di C tranne i gate NOT.
Per l'output di R, abbiamo i qubit che
corrispondono all'output di C, e qui quei qubit
sono raffigurati in alto,
sebbene alla fine di tutto questo non abbia importanza
se sono in alto o no.
Per essere precisi, assumendo di aver eseguito R su uno stato di base standard corrispondente a una
stringa di N bit arbitraria X,
questi M qubit di output saranno nello stato di base standard
corrispondente a F di X.
Abbiamo anche tutti i qubit rimanenti dai gate AND e OR.
Dobbiamo ancora tener conto di loro, e se li raccogliamo tutti insieme, saranno in qualche stato di base standard.
Qualunque sia lo stato di base standard, deve essere una funzione della stringa X, e daremo
a quella funzione il nome G.
Quindi G è una nuova funzione che è
determinata dai gate di C e ci dice in quale stato
si trovano questi qubit rimanenti
dopo l'esecuzione di R. G è la lettera successiva dopo F, quindi questo è un motivo per
chiamare questa funzione G,
ma un altro motivo per chiamarla G è che G sta per garbage (spazzatura).
Questi sono tutti qubit spazzatura, e in particolare abbiamo
due qubit spazzatura per ogni gate AND e per ogni gate OR.
Il numero totale di gate
di cui abbiamo bisogno è O-grande di T.
Questo perché per ogni gate di C, abbiamo bisogno di un numero limitato di quantum gate.
Il gate OR è il più costoso. Per quello, abbiamo bisogno di tre gate NOT insieme a un gate Toffoli,
e un gate Toffoli ci costa 15 gate dal nostro insieme di gate standard.
Quindi sono al massimo 18 gate
in R per ogni gate di C.
Se volessi ottimizzare questo potresti farlo, ma ai fini di un'analisi
asintotica approssimativa, possiamo semplicemente dire che
R ha O-grande di T gate.
Siamo quindi riusciti a
calcolare la stessa funzione F che il Boolean circuit originale
C calcolava,
e lo abbiamo fatto a un costo lineare nella dimensione di C.
Se ci interessa solo
calcolare questa funzione F, allora abbiamo finito.
Ma purtroppo abbiamo
questi qubit spazzatura e questi qubit spazzatura
rovineranno generalmente
i pattern di interferenza che fanno funzionare gli algoritmi quantistici se proviamo a usare questo
circuit R come subroutine
all'interno di un algoritmo quantistico più grande.
Ma possiamo in effetti sbarazzarci di questa spazzatura, e il modo in cui possiamo farlo è sfruttare il fatto che il circuit R può essere invertito,
WEBVTT
o in altre parole, possiamo
eseguirlo al contrario.
Per illustrare come funziona, immaginiamo di eseguire prima R e poi R al contrario,
che possiamo esprimere come R-dagger.
Per essere chiari su questo, ciò significa che applichiamo i gate
di R in ordine inverso e prendiamo gli inversi
di ciascuno dei gate.
I gate NOT, i gate controlled NOT
e i gate Toffoli sono in realtà i propri inversi, quindi se stiamo pensando in
termini di questi gate,
allora R-dagger è davvero solo R con i gate applicati
in ordine inverso.
Ma in generale, possiamo sempre eseguire qualsiasi quantum circuit unitario al contrario nel modo che ho appena descritto,
ovvero applichiamo i
gate in ordine inverso e sostituiamo ciascuno dei
singoli gate con il suo inverso.
Se dovessimo fare questo, scopriremmo che eseguire prima R e poi R al contrario non fa assolutamente nulla.
Quindi, se siamo partiti da uno stato di base standard come abbiamo qui, finiremmo esattamente nello stesso stato di base standard.
Naturalmente, fare solo
questo non è molto utile, ma quello che possiamo fare è introdurre un gruppo di qubit extra e nello specifico,
questi sono M qubit dove M è il numero di bit di output del circuit C.
Questi qubit aggiuntivi potrebbero
essere in qualsiasi stato quantistico, ma per spiegare come funziona, assumeremo che siano in uno stato di base standard
corrispondente a qualche stringa Y. Quindi Y è una stringa di M bit, e quello che possiamo fare è eseguire
un gruppo di gate controlled NOT
come vedi qui, che effettivamente fa lo XOR della stringa F di X
sulla stringa Y memorizzata
in questi M qubit inferiori.
E quindi l'output di
l'intero calcolo è come appare sullo schermo.
X e Y sono stringhe binarie arbitrarie. X ha N bit e Y ha M bit, e abbiamo anche bisogno di K qubit di workspace.
Quando eseguiamo R, calcoliamo F di X e quella stringa è memorizzata
nei top M qubit, ma abbiamo anche un gruppo di qubit spazzatura,
quindi facciamo lo XOR dell'output F di
X sui bottom M qubit e poi eseguiamo R al contrario
per ripulire la spazzatura.
Devo sottolineare che è importante che R sia deterministico.
Se questi top M qubit fossero invece in qualche sovrapposizione
di stati di base standard, questo non funzionerebbe correttamente,
ma funziona quando
R è deterministico.
Quindi se confrontiamo il quantum circuit
che abbiamo appena costruito con il Boolean circuit originale C, vediamo che funziona fondamentalmente
nello stesso modo
in cui funziona un query gate
per una funzione arbitraria.
C'è una differenza qui, ovvero che abbiamo bisogno
di questi qubit di workspace per far funzionare tutto, ma altrimenti abbiamo
effettivamente costruito un query gate
o un query circuit per qualunque funzione sia calcolata da C.
Siamo anche riusciti, tra l'altro, a riportare i qubit di workspace al loro stato iniziale, quindi potrebbero in linea di principio essere riutilizzati
come qubit di workspace per
calcoli successivi.
Se vogliamo, possiamo mettere una scatola attorno all'intero quantum circuit e chiamarlo Q, e la relazione con
C diventa più chiara.
Il circuit Q sarà
più grande di C in generale. Abbiamo bisogno di un po' di quantum gate in Q per ogni gate di C,
e abbiamo anche bisogno dei gate controlled NOT
nel mezzo, ma il numero è comunque
lineare nella dimensione di C.
Va anche notato che questa è una procedura completamente generale che funziona per qualsiasi Boolean circuit, e non abbiamo cercato affatto di ottimizzare Q.
Per un circuit specifico C, potrebbero ben esserci
modi per ridurre la dimensione di Q, incluso l'uso di metodi
che riducono il numero di
qubit di workspace necessari nel caso in cui sia qualcosa
che vogliamo fare, ed è la procedura per eseguire
calcoli classici
su un computer quantistico.
È abbastanza semplice, ma è una cosa importante
da saper fare.
In particolare, ora che
sappiamo come farlo, siamo liberi di sfruttare qualsiasi calcolo classico vogliamo
all'interno dei calcoli quantistici, a condizione di seguire questa forma in cui l'input viene restituito in eco e l'output viene XORato
su un gruppo di qubit
proprio come avevamo per i query gate.
Il costo scala linearmente. Quindi, per esempio, possiamo
creare quantum circuit per problemi come l'addizione intera,
la moltiplicazione, la divisione, il calcolo degli MCD e l'esponenziazione modulare, e tutto questo può essere fatto allo stesso costo asintotico
dei Boolean circuit.
Abbiamo bisogno di qubit di workspace per farlo, ma almeno possono essere riutilizzati quando
abbiamo finito con loro.
Un'ultima osservazione che vale la pena menzionare è che questo metodo ci fornisce un modo per implementare i query gate,
a cui ho accennato nella lezione precedente.
cui ho accennato nella lezione precedente.
Ovvero, se abbiamo un algoritmo di query che prende come input una certa funzione F, e abbiamo un modo per calcolare
F con un Boolean circuit,
possiamo seguire questa procedura per costruire un query gate per quella funzione e poi eseguire il nostro algoritmo di query su di esso.
Se sia una cosa utile da fare dipende dal problema di query stesso e da cosa stiamo cercando di realizzare, ma in sostanza questa
costruzione ci fornisce
un modo per connettere il modello di query a un modello di calcolo più standard.
Questo è in un certo senso il modo in cui funziona l'algoritmo di Shor per la fattorizzazione intera.
WEBVTT
Costruiremo
quantum circuit come questo a partire da alcune delle operazioni aritmetiche di cui abbiamo parlato prima nella lezione.
E facendo questo, diamo ai quantum circuit la capacità di valutare quelle operazioni su sovrapposizioni di stati classici.
E come vedremo, questo ci permette di fattorizzare interi in modo efficiente.
Questa è la fine di questa lezione, che si è concentrata principalmente sull'instaurare una base
per gli algoritmi quantistici in un framework computazionale standard non a scatola nera.
Abbiamo parlato del costo computazionale principalmente attraverso la lente dei problemi connessi con la teoria elementare dei numeri.
Abbiamo discusso del costo polinomiale
rispetto a quello esponenziale per le attività computazionali, e abbiamo visto come i calcoli classici
possano essere implementati da quantum circuit in modo pulito e privo di spazzatura, che consente di usarli come subroutine
all'interno di calcoli quantistici più grandi.
Spero che ti unisca a me per la prossima lezione, dove vedremo come l'algoritmo di Shor mette queste idee in pratica, permettendoci di fattorizzare
interi a costo polinomiale.
Arrivederci a presto.